probablemente ustedes ya oyeron el
término esquema ponzi y déjenme dejen
escribirlo esquema ponzi y lo que vamos
a hacer en este vídeo es explicar lo que
es en verdad porque puede que ustedes
sientan que es algún tipo de timo que
tiene que ver con tomar dinero de otras
personas y vamos a hacer un ejemplo de
cómo funciona en la realidad aquí mismo
tengo dos fotos de probablemente los dos
perpetradores más famosos de esquemas
ponzi este es charles ponzi escribirlo
aquí fue nombrado por el obviamente y
luego más recientemente este es bernie
madoff que logró probablemente el
esquema ponzi mayor y más largo de todos
los tiempos quién sabe tal vez hay un
ejemplo mayor y más largo actualmente
que no hemos descubierto pero pero este
es el mayor que conocemos sale y pons y
no fue la primera persona que inventó el
esquema ponzi pero decidieron nombrarlo
por él porque fue la primera persona
quien lo afamo esta ficha policial fue
tomada en los años tempranos del siglo
20 cuando fue agarrado
y perpetrando su esquema entonces cómo
le hacemos comencemos con unos
inversionistas libre monos de las fotos
de estos señores digamos que tengo un
esquema y lo que voy a hacer es
organizar mis a mis inversionistas
tengo a mis inversionistas y luego
digamos que tenemos varios periodos
podemos ver porque los inversionistas
creen por lo menos al inicio que mi
esquema es legítimo digamos que este es
el periodo no sé que son años digamos el
año 1 el 2 año 3 año 4 y años 5 lo que
voy a hacer es escribir para cada
inversionista voy a pensar o voy a
inscribir cuánto dinero creen que tienen
invertido en mi el operador que soy del
esquema ponzi y luego les va a mostrar
exactamente cuánto dinero tengo y cómo
me puedo salir con el hecho de que los
inversionistas crean que soy legítimo
entonces digamos que aquí está el
inversionista
esto va a ser déjenme déjenme poner
escribirlo en otro color de la propiedad
percibida ok el valor percibido del
inversionista y aquí voy a escribir el
valor real total ok
ok valor total
real ok entonces ustedes pueden imaginar
que esta es la cantidad real de dinero
que tengo aquí tenemos el inversionista
en azul y digamos que en el primer año
me da diez mil dólares y digo que tengo
una manera una cierta manera de doblar
su dinero en el segundo año entonces en
el segundo año en realidad no hago nada
con el dinero y pues no sé a lo mejor me
lo estoy gastando en mis yates y trajes
lujosos o quién sabe pero digamos que
luego are dado en una cuenta bancaria
así que pues me da los diez mil dólares
si no hago nada con él no gano ni
siquiera interés no está ni en una
cuenta bancaria digamos que lo tengo
debajo del colchón entonces la realidad
es que después de un año aún tengo diez
mil dólares pero le prometí al
inversionista que yo tenía algún tipo de
esquema genial que podía duplicar su
dinero así que le digo un le digo que ya
no tiene diez mil dólares sino 20 mil
dólares creció el doble y me siento bien
sobre esto porque sé que va a ser va a
estar tan entusiasmado que su dinero de
que su dinero se dobló y va a querer
seguir invirtiendo y no sólo eso sino
que se va digamos a jugar al golf con
sus amigos
jactarse de cómo puede uno invertir
mejor y no sé que les va a decir que se
integren a mi esquema entonces digamos
que convence a un inversionista ok
entonces dice mira este tipo me maneja
maneja mi dinero este tipo sabe lo que
hace
duplicó mi dinero en un año eso es lo
que le dice al inversionista sale
entonces el inversionista ve invierte 15
mil dólares en el segundo año entonces
cuánto valor real tengo en el segundo
año tengo los diez mil iniciales del
inversionista más estos 15 mil ok
déjenme anotar estos 15 mil así que
tengo en total 25 mil dólares correcto
esta es la cantidad real que tengo en mi
cuenta bancaria suponiendo que no lo voy
a gastar en yates y en los trajes
lujosos que dije pero el valor percibido
total déjenme escribirlo en otra línea
ok el valor total
si todo el mundo quisiera todo el todo
el dinero que creían que tenía de vuelta
yo tendría que pagarles 35 mil dólares
pero sabemos que no va a pasar eso creen
que soy tan buen inversionista que
quieren hacer que su dinero crezca tanto
como pueda no entonces sólo hay 25 mil
dólares en este montoncito de dinero ok
pero la gente cree que debería tener 35
mil dólares porque su dinero se duplicó
el del inversionista de verdad ahora
digamos que en el próximo año les envío
un correo que se yo y les digo que otra
vez su dinero se duplicó entonces el
dinero de este tipo dice que ahora va a
tener 40 mil dólares este tipo por aquí
abajo el del b recibe un correo que dice
que ahora ya tiene 30 mil dólares y
luego se van de nuevo a jugar al golf
conocen a su amigo el inversionista se y
le dicen minar los dos hemos invertido
con este tipo y ha duplicado nuestro
dinero en 12 así que
el inversionista se dice ok si mis dos
compañeros parecen legítimos me llevo
bien con ellos voy a meter también mi
dinero con él y digamos que esto es
normalmente como suelen ir las cosas
verdad aquí aquí en realidad no no son
tres inversionistas son cientos a lo
mejor de inversionistas pero bueno este
es más o menos la dinámica que hay
detrás de esto y digamos que este
inversionista se mete 20 mil dólares
entonces cuál es la realidad
concentrémonos en ellas se percibe que
en el año 3 este tipo acaba de
contribuir sus 20 mil dólares y ya cree
que tiene 40 mil dólares ve cree que
tiene 30 mil así que el valor percibido
es 40 más 30 20 son 90 mil dólares
eso es el valor percibido pero el valor
real sólo va a ser estos 25 mil dólares
que tenías que teníamos en el período 2
más los 20 mil dólares que este tipo
acaba de agregar verdad así que la
realidad es 45 mil dólares
digamos que cuando vamos del periodo 3
al periodo 4 o bueno simplemente digamos
que este tipo del tipo a cree que tiene
40 mil dólares y es el periodo en el que
este tipo él se invirtió 20 mil verdad
entonces digamos que el inversionista
dice ya he estado bastante tiempo
invirtiendo quiero sacar mi dinero este
y a lo mejor ustedes pensarán que puede
arruinar el esquema pero va a funcionar
porque han tenido bastantes inversiones
de otros lados para lo suficiente como
para pagarle a este tipo verdad ya
tenemos 45 mil dólares aunque se crea
que haya 90 mil entonces si este tipo
saca todo su dinero jaja si este tipo
saca todo su dinero tengo el dinero para
pagarle verdad tengo 40 mil dólares
aunque la gente crea que haya 90 mil
entonces si sustraemos 40 mil quedan
cinco mil dólares en la cuenta bancaria
y porque este tipo saco su dinero del
valor percibido
en estos 40 mil ya no están ahí le dimos
al tipo a su dinero y ahora el valor
percibido es de 50 mil así que
esencialmente a la gente les debo 50 mil
dólares verdad que es al inversionista
de ella alce pero la realidad es que
sólo tengo cinco mil dólares en la
cuenta bancaria y el escenario más
probable es que yo gastaba el dinero en
mis lujos pequeños verdad no sé
todo el tiempo pero sigamos por otra
manera otra vez este tipo no sólo dobló
su dinero en otro año sino que como son
todos miembros del mismo club de golf ok
ahora este ahora este tipo dicen mira el
esquema es legítimo el esquema el
esquema se legitimizó es legítimo porque
me desdoble mi dinero por dos años
siguientes y pude sacar mi dinero eso lo
dice el inversionista a verdad
pudo sacar su dinero ok entonces puedo
sacar su dinero así que cuando vuelve al
club de golf les dices a los otros dos
tipos que el negocio realmente es
legítimo y luego viene un inversionista
de lo que ya ha cobrado mucho dinero qué
sé yo tenemos mucho dinero y entonces el
inversionista de dice todavía les voy a
dar más dinero daré cien mil dólares y
tal vez hay un montón de personas que
ahora pueden contribuir con 100 mil
dólares y en el próximo año les digo que
doble o que duplique el dinero de
obviamente para que no sea sospechoso
les diré del 40 por ciento del 30 por
ciento pero bueno esto es para que los
números salgan fáciles y entonces en el
año 4 este tipo sacó todo su dinero el
tipo a y ahora él ve cree que tiene 60
mil él se va a creer que tiene 40 mil
dólares 40 mil y el inversionista de
cree que va a tener 200 mil dólares
ok y bueno se me olvidó escribir el
depósito del inversionista de verdad así
que contribuyó con 100 mil dólares yo
sólo tenía cinco mil pero si añadimos
cien mil dólares ahora tendremos ciento
cinco mil dólares en la cuenta porque al
final del tercer periodo pero bueno en
realidad la cantidad percibida de es
decir 150 mil dólares verdad entonces lo
verde es lo que pasa este es el valor
percibido pero bueno ustedes pueden ver
que cuando más dinero viene en realidad
no estoy haciendo nada todos estos todos
estos rendimientos son falsos ahora
realmente tengo 105 mil dólares
ok y esto es al final del periodo 3 al
final del periodo 4 la gente que cree la
gente cree que tengo 300 mil dólares
déjenme escribir eso la gente cree que
tiene 300 mil dólares el esquema pero en
realidad todavía sólo tengo 105 mil
dólares
105 mil dólares
este es el valor real total pero fíjense
si este tipo o cualquiera de los dos
primeros inversionistas quisieran sacar
un poco de su dinero aunque
probablemente no querrían porque no
cualquier esquema duplica tu dinero cada
año ok pero ya ya mostré que yo puedo
devolver ese dinero verdad al b y al se
podría dárselo si lo quisieran verdad
ahora todo se arruinaría si ahora todo
el mundo se asustará o se enojara y
sacarán su dinero en masa o si más
personas sacan su dinero de lo que hay
en el banco verdad ok entonces para que
un esquema ponzi siga funcionando y
bernie madoff podría haber hecho esto
mucho tiempo verdad hay que tener
rendimientos buenos creíbles y legítimos
aunque no son legítimos sólo tiene que
parecer legítimos así que hay más dinero
entrando que saliendo
más dinero entrando
saliendo así que la meta entera de este
esquema ponzi si ustedes son criminales
elegantes no sólo es guardar el dinero
ok pues los diez mil dólares de un
período o lo que sea que haya de un
período el otro no hay que meterla en
alguna cuenta bancaria suiza para poder
escapar después del país
algún día bueno espero que lo hayan
encontrado agradable